welcome to spoiler corner okay let's
talk about the goddamn that's part of
this movie
motherfucking t-rex I'm okay not only
I'm watching this movie thinking really
am I just getting this fucking co2 a
source you know throughout the whole
thing just like know this is like like
with the ginger a/c part three where
they fucking kill the t-rex and stuff I
guess
no but they are building this bitch up
they are like this thing is in the
middle of the park your bike's gone you
know which sought to buy do you know but
like you know it is it's in there and
like these Raptors are getting you know
trying to attack their attack the people
they don't know where to go and stuff in
this you know this monster is you know
trying to get our main characters and
then like the kids just like we need
more teeth which is just a beautifully
done wide I love it and and the party
talks to the the wormies the the wormy
guys still back at like Mission Control
or whatever it's like release it do it
do it is you know what you're asking for
what analogous to it and you don't think
this is a b-movie con Jesus no no I was
like if you're not to mention it's like
you know what Josie was it do it so
there's this giant ass door and it
starts over at Short and she's standing
there's just darkness there and I use
this beautiful chin and you're like well
what the fuck is or what the fuck is you
cuz you kind of forget that all t-rex is
even a player in this and then suddenly
all you complains about how certain
things are done like I knew right away
what the fucking well cuz they spent so
much time on this stupid coke to asuras
I'm just like you know oh my god they
really not get the t-rex but they're
just saving her up did this doors
opening up and then she likes the flare
and it's like oh shit I know what that
means I know what that is you just see
these little bitty highs from the tea
races since the movie at the Music
Building she's there she's not she's not
like a badass she's got a little flare
there and they're here a dinosaur comes
out here
she starts running with the flare and
there's the co2 asaurus you know trying
to attack the people she throws the
flare at the coat - oh sorry for Coke do
circles oh and the t-rex busts through
this skeleton lineup of like another
Tyson two plus three guys I think by the
way there was the Spinosaurus from
Jurassic Park even better even better
that may have been that that would be
the great fuck you to that scene and
Japan goes right and you're thinking oh
my god are they really gonna do this are
they gonna have this fight and they go
in the mists of like all the shops and
in the gift center all that stuff they
have this huge goddamn awesome fight and
some of the Raptors even get involved
you know who tried to help this the
t-rex outdoor area - this thing's grab
them and throw my music's gonna the me
more just me and our main characters are
just trying to back out you know looking
at this thing he brought the lights on
that's how incredible it was and they're
like just eating each other my teacher
and then they start to get the co2
starts to get the t-rex down it's like
no no and I feel like Rocky
live it up get up yeah yeah we gotta get
up ya bum get up and sucessor it and I'm
like oh my god they're not gonna do it
again they're not gonna kill the t-rex
again but then suddenly this Raptor like
blue I think it was blue I pretty sure
was blue blue rushes in from the back
and co2 is like oh and it jumps I was
like rawr rawr - throws the rat
droppings on the t-rex get something and
plates this thing's fucking neck it just
swirls it around like a goddamn bitch
and don't you near the water throws it
against the water and this thing gets up
and it's just it's looking beef but it's
like I'm not down I'm still on co2 I'm
gonna Lazzara and they're just there and
there's a little Raptor and there's the
t-rex they're there they're tired - but
you think what's gonna happen then
you're like wait a minute the water
there was something that I water in your
motherfucking magnet
untap thing comes out and pulls a
fucking deep blue sea fucking cunt mm
and then and then yeah yeah oh oh and
then and then the the t-rex and the
Raptor like stare at each other and it's
like some like gang things like we cool
blood yeah we cool peace out and then
they go their separate ways like weird
and and but by that point and at that
point done just sad there went
pedestrian oh so I'm sharing the other
oh you fucking liar no I was like no I
was applauding right along with
everybody cuz it was amazing like I say
if not more than the IMAX theater and I
thought somebody would look like tossed
up I want you to yeah I would have stood
up i we were doing that I was like wha
oh no we were just having a ball and you
know infinity and it's like oh I guess
we kind of gotta know what happens to
the people they rush it as quickly as
possible which I didn't mind cuz I did
give a shit about them because this
movie know I don't know but when they
don't know no prob but then finally it's
like they just have a few quick lines
like I said me practically nothing and
that cuts to again what it should end on
the t-rex going on top of this building
is like the research bill just goes and
it's circling around it you're just
getting jacked up like that Wars coming
it's gonna be like you yeah just circles
around there's a t-rex there's this
beautiful shot of like the the Sun going
down or the Sun coming up and this is a
Jurassic whoo yeah the dress would grow
to 30 just goes cut to the uncredited
just like fuck that's amazing
yes the t-rex went oh god damn it I love
it because he brings like a pedometer
he's like good Baja my house I I'm not
sure if it's a he or she another did
they make I emailed aside are they
yeah he mentions I think Chris Pratt
matches up and they are a few machine
alright so she's like this much so yeah
just totally worth it
I mean right away you look nervous we're
shy you know what else you know what
else I love about it cuz I'm gonna
interrupt you cuz you like fucking when
I'm sorry Rand early I got it I'd get a
word in earlier really are douchey moves
just fucking talk anyway you know what
else I love it it made me really like
the Raptors like for once they're not
like the evil bad guys it's like Go Go
you get him you can go like all the
Raptors I'm like okay come on take them
down I'm like any worry that could make
me feel sorry for and happy to see
velociraptors is awesome and you shut
your dirty whore mouth when you say you
don't like this movie it was um
definitely worth the price of admission
I mean like I said I mean it was just
between that and then the pterodactyl
scene and the opening just showing off
the park uh I mean it's like I said I
gotta sit through a whole bunch of our
stuff I personally didn't like but it's
like those three scenes we're just like
you this is so cool I can't just make
like a cut where it's nothing but three
scenes just be opening the middle in the
ending um but yeah pretty much they they
don't here's what I like okay Jurassic
Park 3 when we did that review so many
people out there were just well you know
if this dinosaur did exist you would
probably take down the tear end and
there's like a flame war about which one
would really went out to me you shut
your fucking mouth
the t-rex is awesome nobody takes that
bitch down and the fact that they have
her lose to this and buy more about
Soros you know thing is just like no
fuck you fuck you this movie said hey
you know what all the people I bet
thought that you know it no Shelly you
shut your fucking whore mouth this is
amazing this is how it should have gone
down Shh
Shh welcome 143 bricks there there there
it's not top okay
something to keep in mind it's a work of
fiction dinosaurs aren't really running
around so we really don't fucking know
who would have won yes we did the t-rex
because it's make-believe well here's
the thing - and what I say that I I
think we are talking about the realms to
the story they built up the t-rex so
awesome then they throw her away like a
bitch in movie 3 cuz it's just like you
know oh no cuz we gotta do something to
improve that this is our upping the ante
instead of opening up the park like they
showed up mango okay and then that there
there's your problem
there is your problem I actually did the
fact that the t-rex lost to the
Spinosaurus identitaire whatever the
fuck it was the fact that it lost is not
what bothered me we you nailed it there
was like because we took were upping the
ante the fact that they thought that was
upping the ante and that that was any
good is what bother me because I'm like
had it been a really epic fight and that
dinosaur been really intimidating and
somebody like oh my god I've never seen
anything like this on film and I never
will again you know if it were Mad Max
fury road worthy I probably be like okay
that was amazing it's a fact that it
sucked that bothered me it's like I
think like a lot of people it's not just
the fact that the t-rex loss is that it
just sucked it just wasn't a great fight
it wasn't fun to watch it was like but
but but we've upped the ante we've been
like I said like we should have gotten
in that movie I'm gonna do this way if
this was the sequel the original sequel
to Jurassic Park and the t-rex lost to
this thing I still would have felt like
I got my money's worth it would not have
been upset because it is so fucking epic
and even if she did lose she did not go
down like mother like it just like she
fought to the death and if she saved all
their asses by fighting to the death
and she goes down like then at least I
would have been like okay then at least
was totally worth
story-wise I don't know how you would do
that
haven't liked work because again we know
obviously what they were trying to do
know what I'm trying to have is oh man
I'm sorry I - when I'm die and make it
be like okay then oh I'm gonna talk
about it yeah I'm talking about even in
this if the t-rex died I just feel like
what the fuck it's like yeah I don't
know I can't see a scenario even in this
movie where the t-rex dies if you like
that but I'm saying goodbye yeah I'm
saying if it did happen though it would
be less disappointing than three I think
part of three is not just like that the
t-rex died and we all love the
motherfucking t-rex is just it felt like
such a letdown hmm
like a head she gone out like something
like in this movie I think we would have
been more like alright alright it was
pretty bad she called a good fight but
no yeah I'm happy to put up a good fight
earrings yeah but she went down like a
bitch and jp3 and it was not been
impressive and you could just feel the
filmmakers thinking they were being so
awesome and they weren't and that's what
annoyed me
it's that smug kind of like meet ups the
ante when the chart says this will go
over well you know that's what bothered
me about whenever anybody is like well
why were you upset over there fighting
in jp3 because that's how I should have
gone down that this is this is a little
science of it I'm with the fucking
science there is fucking feathers so be
kicking with one wheel fucking though
it's a fucking made-up movie and then
our fucking made-up movie the
motherfucking t-rex always wins
and it is where if this movie was set 65
million years ago maybe that would have
been a different story though I don't
even though those two times it doesn't
really get there at the same time or
even were there 65 million years ago
Pixar will tell us in the good dinosaur
I'm not help on my Vidya not up on my
dinosaur theory source with what the
Cretaceous of the Jurassic period or
that yeah so but point being it's
fucking fiction so yeah and that's it
was amazing in the environment to the
t-rex should win people's fictional I
like you know cuz the science in these
movies is bullshit yeah just oh don't
bother don't even bother
it's they even in movie one it's like
you know this really doesn't hold water
like it any shape report on I love the
way we've tried to break down
well technically even that they done
have funded it because he missed a DNA
of the Frog what that I'm like okay you
read times that though like nobody was
you know sitting here at the time in 99
I still don't know how the fuck you have
you find all these mosquitoes that all
get stuck in SAP all bite the most
popular dinosaurs like fucking ever
I hunt on it with ya you hate them you
fucking fuck thinkers you think you
would bite them more like the ones there
would be total large numbers of that
we're less popular yeah I mean it's just
and you find like every single one of
them it's just whatever fucking odds but
it's like this is the Bohr foot shit
asaurus and is that very impressive
looking it's very small but there are a
lot of them and the mosquitoes
apparently like their boy
um I don't know well it's the same time
today it was just like there was a cool
Essenes what I mean I'm ENGLISH gonna
film ever but I will say this I liked
the movie before that that for me was
the icing on the cake the cherry on top
you will I need for me like for me I was
just saying okay the park and the
pterodactyl
I don't know outside of that I think I'm
like really actually do not like this
film like most and then that scene
happen I'm like oh you made a
complicated I personally I'm gonna say
this I personally liked the fact that
Vincent d'Onofrio's plan was not really
batshit crazy I'm like looking at my
ball done with like dolphins inside I'm
at it I'm like the first of the idea of
militarizing them I'm like not a good
idea but like when he's like no people
are dying we should do something like
okay he's doing it for the wrong reasons
but I'm like it's not a bad plan I loved
the fact that Chris Pratt went along
with like he's like listen we're doing
with or without you and then that's cut
to him like pointing out of memory we're
gonna start here like I I liked that
they could have easily turned him into
Vince Vaughn scary like no no John you
I'll never do this
he doesn't in the ultimate Arsenal
Raptors to eat all the people somehow
the mind the hero yeah in the long run
technically the plan worked because the
Raptors plus the t-rex together what
brought the goddamn thing down so um
tried to go with it any
they're like big surprises or I feel I
do feel like much like the kept script
that there are scenes missing or
something cuz I feel like JD Wong or
Wong scare ya fede Wong's character is
explained better somewhere because I'm
like so was he working for D'Onofrio is
unlike what I feel like there was some
explanation for that some of that it
took me a while to even realize who was
running the part cuz the first I'm just
like why is the helicopter pilot
everywhere and why is he getting so much
information it's like oh he's he's the
oh they're good men did they mention
that he's the owner I get no is goodbye
Bay Park no I'm sure they did I like I
said is there something yeah you know
you're you keep going on um overall of
youth nineties bad guy I've seen way
worse because what still doesn't make it
gone when it comes to show most of his
ideas I didn't think we're that bad I'm
like really I'm like really I expected
him to be way way so much worse and the
corporate the anti corporate message to
be ceases we're doing we're doing it my
way my way like even we just talk to
regulars just like well I'm the bear guy
I'm gonna talk like even people getting
eaten alive it's a magnificent
magnificent come on oh I'm sorry what
would you prefer James Cameron's Avatar
I hate why are you compare it to movies
that I already hate I'm just sayin well
good way this piece of shit
yeah it's not that piece of shit don't
piece of shit shit yeah if the whole
movie was like can't that be fine and
I'm like just go crazies is it silly
mildly not very offensive smelling crap
avatars villain was a piece of shit but
as that's why I'm trying to say is that
as bad as you keep you making out like
this is the worst villain ever I'm like
honestly he was way less worse than the
whole corporate message in lost world
which was just fucking ridiculous minute
like oh by the way this guy's the bad
guy oh by the way Jon Hamm a guy oh by
the way he's giving the comforting
speech at the end that was your big
movie fucking ridiculous in this one I'm
like I could see every single person's
point of view in this film and they're
not all right but I'm like they weren't
is obvious like he
didn't get like D'Onofrio was the
closest but even he I'm like he was
talking and I'm like yeah he's got a
couple of legit no it's alright but even
those points are kind of legit America
it's the way they have him talk like
this the whole tigey's malkovich ching
it me then it's like you embarrassed me
in front of rafter no I love it okay
well here's the other thing he dies
big fucking shock you know but when the
Raptors are eating you're re eating in
my video telephone the nothing is going
to stop fixed Oh Raptor is going to I
like his death too because it's just
like he he wants even that was no fun
just blood splat done come on Rick yeah
you saw at least Samuel Jackson's are if
you don't like just one cuz that made
sense in Montana Samuel Jackson in our
movie haven't be a mathematician and he
takes part in no action scene whatsoever
and disappears off screen and that just
as arm falls it you know Omar I see the
one guy that's into the juice this girl
as a hacker and her hacking just
involves knowing how to use the fucking
computer hack into jack shit dick see
this is abomination baby there's no
fence I'm like the first movie didn't
make any sense like just deal with it
they're all kind of cheesy B movies the
first ones the best but this is the
second best this movie was a plan uh and
I'll get it it's not just I need to
learn now how to take off your fucking
nostalgia goggles no I mean they're they
are all I mean you're right even the
first film as much as we love that we
praise it I think it did sort of break
new ground love that movie I know I it
makes knows no no I was argue not only
is it a B movie it's also it's an
efficient monster movie and like and
it's done very well it does talk about
the stuff that a lot of monster movies
talking about even the corniest ones uh
so but but like I said it's like 22
years later like I I want it even more
I'm like I said maybe think I'm like
what that wasn't enough and it's like
don't see how amazing
but mail makes it through the ad TV this
thing man TV lowered expectations well
there you go did Jurassic Park
we have lowered expectations that he
said that your Messiah of this film I
take that I'm not lying I if you go in
not expecting the greatest movie ever
it's a lot fucking fine there's your
there's your price if you go in not
expecting the great movie ever it's
great it's the nothing if you're going
not expecting to have a good eye
everything that man not everything can
be Mad Max fury road that's what I mean
to say this is not the greatest action
movie ever made
but look like I said I really do think
people going in who want to see this
film and want to have fun during this
film you will most likely enjoy come on
didn't you at least enjoy when they
found the old part of the park why it's
awesome but when these go with these
cars that still work and they never used
to like why are they just like hey you
know we should utilize some of this shit
it's just there you know the dinosaurs
will find it and I don't know maybe
wasn't I'm I don't want to utilize in
1992 Jeep I bet the kids did you can do
anything with that play but now let's
just let the dinosaurs find it and you
know possibly eat something toxic more
batteries of it in there no no I got I
got the direct in well they may have
been outside offense there who knows
where that fuck is a truck man truly
sorry yeah I I always got the impression
that the park had been closed and by the
time they moved back in there to build a
new park they're already like well this
is useless because even in the first
movie it's not that impressive so that
was always my one but why not tear it
down and it's not brother that's just
wasteful that's wasteful man it's engine
they're evil haven't we printed us out
by watching all the other movies I did
that is my one thing about the first
thing that is still kind of fascinates
me I'm like even that original Visitors
Center like looking at it particularly
now in retrospect but even as a kid I'm
like huh thought there would have been
more like I mean mr. naturally now mr.
DNA is nice yeah so I'm sure they just
look there's like
just it be it is 20 years ago but yeah I
do kind of wonder like us well we will
do a mini you want wasteful you're the
one who's telling me that you were on
that fucking MGM or Disney studio a lot
at Disneyworld and they've just got the
fucking flight of the navigator walnut I
would love for them to make a ride out
of line on etiquette you're sitting
there you said there were all these
props and stuff just sitting there on
the open like dalem no but they're the
leather men went off there they were
throwing that set out the same night
into the dumpster like that honestly it
makes much more sense to me that no but
there's still a dumpster there is a
place to put the garbage what are you
two okay you're in the jungle why are
you tearing something down when the
jungle will just grow over it cuz you
can possibly use that stuff for other
things too any car mechanic they can use
some of those parts before something
goddamn it they still work that the
fucking kids are wired it still works
they function you know we're in L
annoyed somebody is not getting their
car parts because they're like oh well
this kind doesn't exist anymore they're
only made them in Jurassic Park oh wait
a minute they're right here why didn't
we just grab them and give them and now
someone's car is dead you know I was
like I thank you sir
see but dumbest argument I can give you
some straws to grasp if you want some
you're making arguments like you know
well why would they do pull tears cuz
you're the one who says why is it still
there no you're the one that won oh
you're like wow that wasn't been amazing
it's like I don't know why I was still
there I did that's all I was saying was
like that was cool to see the original
part of that was both nostalgic and cool
and I prefer the newer stuff but the
actual parkansas which again but I read
your contracts we all we're gonna know
to have none no no actually I forgot to
ask you a person of time not smoke up um
there's a scene where when they're
they're getting a shot of the park and
we saw that IMAX in 3d which is I would
argue not really needed you can just get
oh don't don't no I mean it's not all
for anybody there's no need there's
still nothing in it that you're just
gonna light it but there is what
there's one part with the 3d where
they're they're going over the park and
then they in this big tracking shot and
they order this uh aerial shot and they
go home in on the two kids the two main
boys uh and I swear they were more 3d
than everybody else like they stood out
a little bit more everyone else kind of
look at beard area they looked real I
was almost one maybe that was done
intentionally or that's just an accident
okay in any process there is another
weird ship when they landed in the
helicopter for the first time and I'm
like that looks like a toy hell yeah
looks like a model
it looks like a model toy huh I'm like
what the fuck is going on here like is
this the 3d process was it a bad effect
shot but yeah that was weird
ya know I'd be really weird cuz I'm like
no they're really in there this is a
real shot but what it is it just to
high-def like it but yeah I really look
like a toy helicopter landed but the
characters were really in there wasn't
CGI's I'm like what yeah so um there you
go dude well the coolest anything's ever
the fuckin rekt see this movie don't
listen to it